“Good grief,” said Jotaro Kujo as he,
his grandfather Joseph Joestar, and the rest
of their allied group of stand users hid from
the light of day in the shadows of a ruined
building.
Outside, amorphous semi-humanoid monstrosities
roamed free in search of life.
How could this have happened?
Jotaro’s family had been on some bizarre
adventures, but this one was proving to be
the most bizarre of all.
The Sun, now designated SCP-001, was burning
with intense bright red light and an anomalous
level of heat.
It beat down on the world below like an evil
and sadistic god of the desert.
The entire world was at the mercy of these
oppressive solar rays, and high temperatures
were just the beginning.
From the looks of it, any living thing exposed
to the rays of SCP-001 would quickly dissolve
into a horrible gooey substance that would
ooze towards other organisms in an attempt
to absorb them into its biomass.
Basically, it was like a zombie apocalypse
straight out of an easy bake oven.
The Stardust Crusaders had been passing through
this city on their globe-trotting adventure,
only to find that morning had brought with
it a disaster the likes of which had never
been seen before.
By mid-afternoon, when the sun was highest
in the sky, most of the people had already
been converted into slime monsters, and those
who fled into the shadows found themselves
relentlessly hunted down and absorbed.
Only the stand users of Jotaro’s group,
who were already on the lookout for strange
happenings, had been clever enough to pick
up on the situation immediately.
They had been the subject of many unusual
supernatural attacks over the course of their
journey, so the initial anomalous effects
of SCP-001 seemed to be another routine brush
with an enemy.
“Hey, Jotaro!
This has to be the effect of an enemy stand,
right?”
Joseph said.
“What?
Are you stupid or something, old man?”
spat Jean Pierre Polnareff.
The Frenchman was ever the impulsive one,
and he always found something to complain
about when a woman wasn’t present.
He was selectively polite, one might say.
It was fitting given the fact that his stand,
Silver Chariot, took the form of a sword-wielding
knight and its reaction speed was the fastest
of any of the Stardust Crusaders.
“You think one Stand could do all this?”
Polnareff was adamant about making his point.
Jotaro’s fellow high school classmate Noriaki
Kakyoin was the next to speak.
“Polnareff, keep your voice down.
We can’t be sure it's not a stand, but either
way, those flesh monsters are looking for
us.”
Kakyoin was younger than Polnareff, but tended
to carry himself with more composure.
This likely had something to do with the fact
that Hierophant Green was the group’s most
technical stand and often used for reconnaissance.
“What do you think, Avdol?”
Kakyoin continued.
“You’re the expert here.”
Muhammad Avdol, a fortune teller who possessed
a stand that controls fire - Magician’s
Red - was often knowledgable about the supernatural.
“A stand this powerful would have to be
limited in the range it could affect.”
Avdol said.
“What we have to do is get further away
from this area, then we’ll see if this strange
sunlight fades.”
“But what if the user is following us?”
Joseph interjected.
“How will we know we aren’t putting more
people at risk?”
“Mr. Joestar, we can’t win this battle
without more information,” Avdol replied.
“Kakyoin, your Hierophant Green has the
longest range.
Send it to scout for a place outside of this
stand’s reach.
Our stands shouldn’t be visible to those
transformed humans, and the heat from sunlight
won’t affect something without mass.”
Friendly reminder to those of you at home
unfamiliar with the properties of Stands.
Stands are spectral entities formed from the
soul of the user, and are essentially superpowered
ghosts without physical presence.
As such, they wouldn’t be affected by SCP-001
the way a living thing would.
Now back to this bizarre adventure.
“Right.”
Kakyoin nodded.
“Hierophant Green!”
Kakyoin summoned his stand and began threading
Hierophant Green’s long, stretchy body throughout
the ruins as far as it could go.
The young man concentrated, looking through
the eyes of his stand.
As Kakyoin and his stand searched for the
end of the anomalous effects of SCP-001, Polnareff
continued to complain as usual.
“So we’re still not sure what is going
on, but from what I’ve heard, you’re already
calling it a stand?
Did I get that right, Avdol?”
Polnareff grumbled.
“Do you have any better ideas, Polnareff?”
Avdol said sternly.
“Iggy!”
barked Iggy, the last member of the stardust
crusaders.
He was a Boston terrier who commanded a sand-manipulating
stand known as The Fool.
Iggy didn’t really have much to add to the
conversation, but he liked to be heard.
“Listen…” said Joseph Joestar.
“When I was a younger man, I actually did
go head-to-head with some terrifying beings
who might be able to turn people into monsters
like those, but every single time the sun
was the enemy of those guys.”
“Nobody is interested in hearing your stories
right now, old man,” Jotaro chided his grandfather.
Meanwhile, far from where the Stardust Crusaders
were hiding out, Hierophant Green was reaching
the limits of its effective range and seeing
no sign of an end to the anomalous effects.
Kakyoin was baffled.
Could it be true that the entire world had
been affected by the frightening ability of
the sun now that it was SCP-001?
If that was true then this apocalyptic wasteland
was more than just the work of an enemy stand
user.
This would mean that the sun itself had become
the enemy of all life.
Kakyoin wondered about his family back in
Japan: would they manage to survive this terrible
catastrophe?
He couldn’t help but hope that there was
some way out of this utter devastation, even
though the information gathered by his stand
told him otherwise.
Kakyoin withdrew Hierophant Green and brought
his companions up to speed.
However hard it was to accept, the world as
they knew it was gone with the daybreak.
Polnareff was beside himself in sadness, while
Avdol and Joseph exchanged a meaningful glance.
For once, Iggy’s bad attitude subsided,
and the dog simply whimpered.
Only Jotaro remained determined to carry on.
“Good grief, would all of you get a hold
of yourselves?”
Jotaro said.
“We’ll remain human as long as we aren't
caught in that light, so I’ll use Star Platinum
to tunnel our way underground.”
Jotaro’s Star Platinum was a short-range
stand, but in terms of raw power it was off
the charts.
Its punches could easily tunnel through solid
rock and create a subterranean passageway
for the Crusaders to retreat to a safer area.
“Thattaboy, Jotaro!”
Joseph exclaimed.
“We’ll make our daring escape, mole-style!
”
Jotaro nodded and called Star Platinum.
Shouting its signature battle cry of “ora
ora!!”
Star Platinum smashed through the earth below,
instantly creating the entrance to a tunnel.
At that exact moment, every flesh monster
in the nearby vicinity turned its attention
towards the sound.
The stand users had to move quickly, because
they would soon be completely surrounded.
“OH MY GOD!!!”
shouted Joseph in his usual way, as a couple
of flesh monsters began to enter the ruined
building.
Luckily, Polnareff and Avdol sprung into action
and summoned Silver Chariot and Magician’s
Red to fend off the flesh zombies.
Silver Chariot delivered an inescapably fast
flurry of sword strikes to one of the monsters,
while Magician’s Red burned them away with
its supernatural flames.
The two men high-fived at a job well done.
Just then, the wall next to them burst open,
revealing a new monster and causing the sun’s
rays to enter into the building’s interior.
With split-second intuition, Avdol pushed
Polnareff further into the shadows.
The Frenchman tumbled backwards into the hole
Jotaro made, and before he could get his bearings,
he caught a glimpse of Avdol being absorbed
into the monster’s mass.
“AVDOL!”
He cried out.
But it was too late, Avdol was already starting
to show signs of transformation into an ooze-like
zombie himself.
The fortune teller breathed in deep, and called
the name of his stand with determined fervor.
“Magician’s Red!”
Before Avdol could fully be taken by the slime,
he unleashed the totality of his fire power
on every zombified lifeform within range,
its destructive heat enhanced by the dryness
of the atmosphere.
Avdol turned back to his friends and gave
them a heartful thumbs up before he disappeared
into the flames.
Polnareff cried out for his friend again,
with tears in his eyes, but Kakyoin and Joseph
grabbed him and made their way deeper into
the tunnel.
As badass and heroic as it was, Avdol’s
sacrifice wouldn’t keep those hordes of
monsters at bay for long.
While Kaykoin and Joseph dragged a crying
Polnareff through the underground escape route,
Jotaro and Iggy were already at the front
of the group, using a combination of Star
Platinum’s digging ability and Iggy’s
sand manipulation to stabilize the tunnel.
The Stardust Crusaders were deep beneath the
surface of the earth now, so a cave-in could
be a real problem.
“We have to go back!!”
Polnareff shrieked.
“Avdol needs our help!”
“It’s too late, Polnareff.”
Joseph said, with grim conviction.
“Avdol is gone.”
“We don’t know that for sure!”
Polnareff carried on.
“Let me go!”
But Kakyoin and Joseph held onto Polnareff
tightly and continued to drag him down the
passageway, hoping not to lose him to this
daytime nightmare as well.
On the inside, Jotaro was shaken by the loss
of one of his companions, but nobody would
have been able to tell by looking at his stoic
exterior.
He was entirely focused on keeping the tunnel
expanding so that he and the remaining Crusaders
could survive this ordeal together.
Suddenly, a noise from the opposite end of
the passage put the group on high alert.
Like a flood of liquified horror, the flesh
monsters had begun pouring themselves into
the pit and were now moving towards the group
inch by inch.
“OH NOOOO!!!”
Joseph shouted.
He loosened his grip on Polnareff, and both
of them immediately booked it towards Jotaro
and Iggy.
Kakyoin, however, stood in place and braced
himself.
He didn’t like it, but he knew what he had
to do.
Right now, his stand had the ability to stop
these things, but first, he had to slow them
down.
“Emerald Splash!”
Kakyoin shouted, prompting Hierophant Green
to launch a stream of concussive green gemstones
from its hands.
As planned, the attack slowed the slime monsters
down.
Kakyoin was then able to put the second part
of his plan into effect.
He identified what appeared to be a face on
the monster in front, and sent Hierophant
Green to make its way inside the creature’s
body.
This was his stand’s most terrifying ability,
and one Kakyoin seldom used: Hierophant Green
had the power to control the bodies of other
physical entities from within.
Once his stand had established control, Kakyoin
forced the massive ooze to stop in place,
instantly plugging the tunnel and preventing
the rest of the monsters from getting any
closer.
How long could he keep this up, he didn’t
know, but because of Hierophant Green’s
properties as a remote stand, Kakyoin was
able to run to rejoin Jotaro and the others
at the front of the tunnel.
The tether between himself and his stand was
stretching farther by the minute, but he dared
not let his control of the oozing entity slip,
lest he and his companions suffer the same
fate as Avdol.
Before long, Jotaro felt a different sort
of surface at the front of the tunnel.
Rather than earth, it was brick.
With one punch from Star Platinum, he smashed
through and into what appeared to be an abandoned
subway station.
The power was still on, though most of the
lights had faded.
It was fortunate that there was no natural
sunlight in this place.
As everyone’s eyes adjusted to the light,
the stand users crossed the tracks and made
their way onto the somewhat safer area.
Polnareff drifted over to the magazine kiosk,
searching for signs of anyone behind the counter.
There was nobody here, and Iggy soon helped
himself to some of the coffee-flavored chewing
gum at the concession stand.
The dog couldn’t resist his favorite snack
after all.
Jotaro stood by the tracks, as if waiting
for a train, while Kakyoin did his best to
maintain his hold on the monsters further
behind them in the tunnel.
With a bit of searching, Joseph found a large
portable music player designed for CDs, also
known as a boom box.
With the use of his divination-focused stand,
Hermit Purple, Joseph created purple thorny
vines which weaved their way into the wires
of the device and generated a psychic message.
Hermit Purple could usually be counted on
to provide more detail about a situation,
but its powers were limited by the device
used to gain the information.
In this case, the CD within the boom box had
a copy of The Beatles’ famous 1969 album
Abbey Road, so Hermit Purple’s message to
Joseph came out as a garbled but oddly appropriate
rearrangement of the lyrics to Here Comes
The Sun.
Little darlin’, I see their faces slowly
melting
Little darlin’, it seems like years since
it’s been alright
Here comes the sun
Here comes the sun, and I say
I feel I been slowly melting
Sun, Sun, Sun, Here it comes
“Oh my god,” Joseph said to himself quietly.
Just then, Kakyoin felt the body that Hierophant
Green was controlling give way.
Apparently, the pressure of so many other
ooze monsters had been too much for it to
hold back, and now these things were barreling
down the tunnel towards the Crusaders.
Rather than pulling Hierophant Green back
completely, Kakyoin unleashed his emerald
splash over and over again in an attempt to
force a cave in.
But the creatures were too resilient, and
their ooze-like structure meant they could
squeeze past mere rocks in their path.
Kakyoin told the rest of the group that it
was time to leave, and as if on cue, a train
began to pull into the station.
Unfortunately, the crazy train pulled into
the station with several cars full of ooze
zombies ready to grab the poor team and drag
them into the sun.
There was no way out but up the stairs.
Back into the sunlight they had done everything
possible to escape.
As Polnareff, Jotaro, Joseph, and Iggy did
their best to fend off the attacking creatures
using their stands, Kakyoin made one last
ditch attempt to contain the monsters.
He stretched Hierophant Green down to its
most basic form, a series of long green fibrous
strings and created a net to ensnare the creatures.
While the oozes could still seep through this
wiry form, Kakyoin rigged his stand to set
off an emerald splash on every bit of anomalous
goo that made it past the nets defenses.
It was a sustainable and effective wall against
the monsters, using both the tensile strength
of the stand and its energy attacks to effectively
stymie their progress.
There was only one problem.
In order to maintain this perfect defense,
Kakyoin would have to stay behind.
“I’ll hold them.
Go on without me!”
Kakyoin said.
“KAKYOIN!!”
Joseph shouted, as the rest of them ran as
fast as they could out of the subway.
Having effectively lost two members of the
group, The Stardust Crusaders were in low
spirits.
Looking up through the subway exit, they could
see that they would soon be in contact with
the sunlight, meaning that even their survival
would become unlikely.
But Jotaro wasn’t about to give in.
He grabbed Iggy and held the dog out in front
of him.
“Alright, Iggy, it’s now or never.
Either show us you can be a team player or
be the first to turn into one of those blob
monsters.”
Iggy struggled in Jotaro’s grip, but to
no avail.
The dog knew that Jotaro was serious, so in
an act of self-preservation that was usually
generous of him, Iggy used The Fool to stir
up the sand on the ground above into a gigantic
shady sand dome.
Moments later, he compressed it into a compact
fortress of sand.
Iggy’s moving castle, as it were.
No light could enter this fortress, but because
of the granular nature of sand, oxygen was
flowing freely.
The Stardust Crusaders now had a method of
travel in this world torn apart by SCP-001.
Of course, there was still the matter of dealing
with the flesh creatures outside.
Even if the fortress of sand could move across
the surface without sunlight getting in, the
surrounding oozes could still impede its progress.
With the help of all three of Jotaro, Joseph,
and Polnareff stands, a solution soon became
clear.
Joseph would use Hermit Purple on the sand
to divine the location of any approaching
threats, while Jotaro and Polnareff would
patrol the outside of the miniaturized fortress
with Star Platinum and Silver Chariot, respectively.
That way, whenever a flesh creature got too
close, the two attack-type stands could unleash
full-force barrages to knock them away.
The next thing to do was for Iggy to increase
the speed of the sand construct by adding
wheels to it.
It was like a giant sand monster truck zooming
through the ruins, with a platinum brawler
and a silver knight repelling anything that
came too near.
Once Iggy gained enough velocity with The
Fool, Joseph used Hermit Purple to discern
the location of a bit of rubble shaped conveniently
like a ramp.
The sandcastle vaulted off the ramp and into
the air where Iggy augmented his creation
once again with a pair of gigantic gliding
wings.
Now they were soaring.
Out of the reach of the flesh monsters, Joseph
and Polnareff shared sympathies over the loss
of their two important friends.
Avdol and Kakyoin had both bravely given themselves
to protect the team, and none of the Crusaders
would be here if it wasn’t for them.
Jotaro focused on helping Iggy pilot the sand-glider,
using Star Platinum to kick the ground whenever
the vehicle got too low.
Nobody was sure what they would encounter
next in the daybreak, or what bizarre adventures
were yet to unfold, but they had each other
and for now, that was enough.
Now go check out “I Survived 100 Days of
SCP-001 When Day Breaks...
Here's What Happened” and “SCP-001 When
Day Breaks Tale (Hour by Hour)” for more
horrifying When Day Breaks action!